[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
beim EU-Gipfel in Brüssel sitzen die
Staats- und Regierungschefs jetzt beim
Abendessen zusammen da laufen die
Gespräche weniger formell und man würde
schon gerne zuhören wieder zum Beispiel
Russland geredet wird spekulationsstoff
gibt es ja reichlich etwa ob es stimmt
das Putin einen seiner ranghöchsten
Generäle den Vize-Chef des Generalstabs
wegen Verdacht auf Verrat hat festnehmen
lassen
Bestätigungen dafür gibt es nicht aber
der Mann wurde seit der Wagner Meuterei
nicht mehr öffentlich gesehen
die Europäer bzw alle EU-Staaten mit
Ausnahme Ungarns wollen bei diesem
Gipfel auch ein klares Signal an Putin
senden die Unterstützung für die Ukraine
werde weitergehen Isabel Schäfers
berichtet
Europas liberale sind schon einen
Schritt weiter als die EU selenskis
Partei Diener des Volkes ist schon jetzt
Mitglied der europäischen liberalen
Partei beim Treffen vor dem EU-Gipfel in
Brüssel heute morgen wirft der
ukrainische Fraktionsvorsitzende einem
EU-Mitglied vor auf der falschen Seite
zu stehen
meiner Meinung nach ist Viktor Orban
einer Gent in der EU um russische Werte
zu verteidigen statt europäischer Werte
das ist offensichtlich
offensichtlich ist zumindest eins Ungarn
blockiert die EU unter anderem weitere
500 Millionen Euro Militärhilfe für die
Ukraine alle anderen Senden von diesem
EU-Gipfel aber erneut ein Signal der
Geschlossenheit an den zugeschalteten
ukrainischen Präsidenten volle
Unterstützung für die Ukraine wir sind
müssen uns darauf einstellen dass das
lange dauern kann und deshalb ist es
auch bedeutend dass wir hier uns
unterhaken und sagen wir sind bereit das
auch lange durchzuhalten was an
finanzieller humanitärer Unterstützung
für die Ukraine notwendig ist aber auch
wenn es etwa um Waffen gibt auch Europa
hat er weiterhin unerklärliche Aufstand
der wagnergruppe in Russland in
Alarmbereitschaft versetzt
Satellitenaufnahmen aus Belarus
südöstlich von Minsk zeigen womöglich
eine neue Militäranlage für
Söldnergruppe
Situation macht den angrenzenden
EU-Staaten sorgen und die Bedrohung wäre
wahrscheinlich keine frontale
militärische aber die Gefahr einer
versuchten Infiltration nach Europa
besteht das bedeutet dass wir unsere
Aufmerksamkeit für die Grenzen schärfen
und sicherstellen müssen dass wir das
kontrollieren können
zusammen mit Polen blockiert Ungarn noch
mehr beide wollen den gerade
geschlossenen Asylkompromiss nicht
mittragen keine Flüchtlinge aufnehmen
nicht zahlen
Nein zu illegaler Migration Nein zu
finanzstrafen und Sanktionen und ein
Nein zu einer Entscheidung ohne
Einstimmigkeit
aber beim Thema Migration haben auch
andere noch Bedenken trotz vereinbartem
Kompromiss streitet Europa weiter Länder
wie Deutschland wollen höhere
Menschenrecht Standards andere Europa
abschotten diese Uneinigkeit macht auch
die Verhandlungen mit dem
Europaparlament nicht leichter
Migration darf nicht instrumentalisiert
werden wir sind es unseren Bürgern
schuldig eine Einigung noch vor der
Europawahl zu finden wir müssen gerechte
und menschliche Lösungen finden
aber um genau diese Lösungen wird wohl
noch lange gerungen werden
und Fräulein Brüssel könnten die anderen
EU-Länder nicht sagen ja gut dann machen
wir es ohne euch ohne Polen und Ungarn
und gab es nicht auch die Idee dass
einzelne Länder sich quasi frei kaufen
können
ja diese Idee des freikaufens wenn man
keine Flüchtlinge aufnimmt dass man dann
quasi eine Strafzahlung macht die gab es
die ist eigentlich extra für Polen und
Ungarn erfunden worden aber diese beiden
Länder haben heute noch mal sehr
deutlich auf dem Gipfel gemacht dass sie
den kompletten asyl-kompromiss ablehnen
auch nicht vorhaben sich frei zu kaufen
sondern sie wollen diesen
asyl-kompromiss boykottieren man muss
sich das einmal kurz auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen es gibt einen
mehrheitlichen Beschluss des EU-Rates
also der Regierungschefs und Ungarn und
Polen sagen das interessiert uns nicht
man hat das jetzt zur Kenntnis genommen
und gesagt wir machen jetzt weiter ohne
sie und wird jetzt mit dem EU-Parlament
verhandeln um zu gucken dass man da ein
Kompromiss hinbekommt und wenn man
diesen Kompromiss hat wird es dann
irgendwann ein Gesetz geben und dieses
Gesetz geht und da hat auch schon Polen
und Ungarn angedeutet dass auch dass sie
nicht interessiert und das könnte dann
vor den Gerichten landen und da wiederum
hat Polen und Ungarn noch mal angedeutet
wenn man sie zwingt diesen
Asylkompromiss der dann irgendwann
ausgehandelt ist anzunehmen dann würden
sie andere EU-Entscheidung boykottieren
also man sieht dieses Thema Asyl hat
sehr sehr viel Gift hier innerhalb der
Union beim Thema ukraine-shirt zumindest
Ungarn ja auch aus auch schon ja
ziemlich auffällige Weise das stimmt
Ungarn ist irgendwie das Land dass ich
hier sehr stark also in Szene setzt und
immer wieder Schwierigkeiten macht
allerdings bei der Ukraine Hilfe ist
eine andere Lage es wird wirtschaftliche
Hilfe geben und es wird weiter vor allem
auch militärische Hilfe geben das ist
sehr sehr klar geworden man hat auch
noch mal die Schluss Erklärung hier von
den Gipfel sehr deutlich gemacht dass
man Ungarn weiter und so lange
unterstützt wie das nötig ist es ist
doch etwas Bemerkenswertes hier passiert
dieser Krieg ist ja ein werteduell so
hat man das auch immer aufgefasst und
eigentlich sind die Diktatoren Putin und
auch der chinesische Ping davon
ausgegangen dass die Demokratien
irgendwann müde werden nur werden sich
zerstreiten en über diese Unterstützung
der Ukraine und genau das Gegenteil ist
passiert Europa steht sehr geschlossen
da und in Russland rieselt dies ist hier
sehr klar noch mal auch zum Ausdruck
gebracht worden und das motiviert viele
auch auf diesem Weg weiter zu machen
also beim Thema Ukraine ein ganz klares
Zeichen Richtung Moskau die EU steht
danke schön
den Ukrainern ist es wichtig dass der
Wiederaufbau nicht erst beginnt wenn der
Krieg vorbei ist wann immer dass der
Fall sein wird für das wirtschaftliche
Überleben des Landes und schlicht auch
für die Moral der Bevölkerung kommt es
darauf an dass Infrastruktur schnell
wieder repariert wird das ist Strom und
Wasser gibt Kliniken Schulen Supermärkte
und Wohnraum ganz abgesehen davon dass
der Anblick zerbombte Häuser immer
wieder aufs Neue traumatisiert doch
vielerorts gelingt das nicht es fehlt an
allem berichtet unsere Reporter daran er
ist in der schwer umkämpften Region SAP
Berisha
der Blick ins Innere einer Wohnung die
Folgen eines russischen raketenangriffs
der dieses Wohnhaus in saporischer
zerstört hat es geschah im vergangenen
Sommer und es ist nur eines von mehr als
1100 Gebäuden den saporischer getroffen
wurden es mangele nicht an
Arbeitskräften sagte Bürgermeister es
fehlt ein Geld um sie zu bezahlen
heute haben wir ein Loch in der
Stadtkasse aufgrund des Krieges stehen
die meisten der großen Fabriken still
sie produzieren nicht wir haben
Steuerausfälle die wir nicht ausgleichen
können in unserem Budget für den
Wiederaufbau brauchen wir Hilfe in
erster Linie Geldmittel
in der Ukraine sind mehr als 163.000
Gebäude seit Kriegsbeginn durch
russische Angriffe beschädigt oder
zerstört worden das entspricht 8,6% des
Wohnungsbestandes der Zug kommt die
Zerstörung von Infrastruktur wie das
kachowska Staudamms überschwemmte
Ortschaften verunreinigte Böden sind
genug der Herausforderung der
Wiederaufbau in der Ukraine beginnt
mitten im Krieg der Erfolg hängt vor
allem von der Flugabwehr ab
der Waffenlieferungen unserer westlichen
Partner insbesondere von
Flugabwehrsystem haben wir jetzt weniger
Einschläge die Menschen sehen das und
kommen zurück und wenn Menschen kommen
kommt auch das Geschäft zurück
zumindest in den Straßencafés hat die
Rückkehr der Gäste begonnen selbst dort
wo die Spuren des Kriegs noch sichtbar
sind die Druckwelle einer
raketenexplosion hat Nicolas Café
beschädigt
am Anfang war es hart zur Arbeit zu
gehen und jeden Tag die Zerstörung zu
sehen
aber mit der Zeit gewöhnt man sich daran
nun was heißt gewöhnt
im Inneren nagt es weiter an der Seele
aber wir müssen überleben auch unter
diesen Umständen das ist unsere Realität
das wieder eröffnete Café ist ein
Hoffnungsschimmer mehr nicht ohne
Milliarden Hilfe wird er Wiederaufbau in
der Ukraine nicht gelingen
viele Hintergründe zum Ukraine Krieg und
seinen Folgen finden Sie auch online auf
ZDF heute und nach unserer Sendung
diskutiert Maybrit Illner mit ihren
Gästen über die Vorgänge in Russland und
die Frage ob ein Machtkampf in Moskau
Chance oder gefallen
jetzt geht es aber erstmal mit den
Nachrichten weiter und zwar zuerst mit
dem Tarifstreit bei der bahnheizt ja in
diesem festgefahrenen tarifstreik
zwischen der Deutschen Bahn und der
Eisenbahn und Verkehrsgewerkschaft EVG
sind weitere Warnstreiks vorerst vom
Tisch nach dem gestern die Bahn
Gespräche für eine Schlichtung
vorgeschlagen hatte sprach sich dafür
heute auch der evg-vorstand aus an der
Urabstimmung werde aber festgehalten und
damit auch an der Möglichkeit
unbefristete Arbeitskämpfe
Bundesverkehrsminister Wissing hat zur
Förderung der Elektromobilität zwei
Programme mit insgesamt 900 Millionen
Euro angekündigt es geht um die Lade
Infrastruktur im Bereich der
Privathaushalte sind ab Herbst 500
Millionen Euro vorgesehen für
Ladestationen kombiniert mit
photovoltaik-firmen Lieferdienste oder
Handwerker
der Chemiekonzern BASF hat in
Schwarzheide in Brandenburg die erste
deutsche Großanlage eröffnet in der
Materialien zum Bau von Lithium-Ionen
Batterien hergestellt und alte Batterien
recycelt werden sollen
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck betonte
die Wichtigkeit des Standortes in der
Lausitz für eine unabhängige
Wertschöpfungskette in Europa in der
Fabrik können künftig unter anderem
Materialien für die Batterieproduktion
für etwa 400.000 E-Autos pro Jahr
hergestellt werden
in Deutschland ist Rassismus gegenüber
Muslimen in weiten Teilen der
Gesellschaft verbreitet das stellt laut
Bundesinnenministerium der
Abschlussbericht unabhängige Experten
fest der heute nach dreijähriger
Untersuchung vorgestellt wurde demnach
erlebten viele der 5,5 Millionen
Musliminnen und Muslime Ausgrenzung und
Diskriminierungen im Alltag bis hin zu
Hass und Gewalt
einen antisemitischen Übergriff hat es
nach Angaben der Stadtverwaltung in
Frankfurt am Main gegeben eine Gruppe
Jugendliche habe an einer
Erinnerungsstätte jüdische Besucher
zunächst mit Worten einzuschüchtern
versucht dann sei eine Flasche geworfen
worden die nur knapp den Kopf einer der
BesucherInnen verfehlt habe der
Staatsschutz habe die Ermittlungen
übernommen
der Oberste Gerichtshof in den USA hat
Aufnahmeverfahren an Universitäten für
verfassungswidrig erklärt mit denen
Minderheiten wie Afroamerikaner oder
hispaniks gefördert werden sollen die
sogenannte effirmative Action verstoße
gegen den Gleichheitsgrundsatz in den
konkreten Fällen sahen die Kläger eine
Benachteiligung von asiatisch stämmigen
und weißen Bewerbern 2016 hatte das
Gericht entsprechend der Regelungen noch
als rechtens betrachtet danach
veränderte sich aber dessen Besetzung
nun sind es mehrheitlich konservative
Richter mehr Hintergründe und Reaktionen
später im heute-
ein Sanitäter in Notar schrie ist voller
Wut und Entsetzen heraus der Junge war
erst 17 und ihr habt ihn wegen eines
verkehrsdelikts erschossen das war
vorgestern unmittelbar nach den
Geschehnissen aber der Sanitäter
prophezeite den Umstehenden Polizisten
auch schon was folgen würde Aufstände in
der bornhöhe es brennt in Frankreichs
Vorstädten nicht mehr nur in Notar dem
Vorort von Paris das Weg Erinnerungen an
die Unruhen 2005 als am Ende sogar der
Notstand ausgerufen wurde die große
Frage ist ob es der Regierung ob es
macron gelingt die Lage wieder zu
beruhigen Hannah Arendt berichtet aus
Frankreich
platzt der Menschenrechte Monja die
Mutter des getöteten Jugendlichen hat zu
einem Trauermarsch aufgerufen und
tausende sind ihr gefolgt voller Wut auf
die Polizei und auf den Staat
wir trauern um Neil es ist schlimm was
ihm passiert ist und er ist kein
Einzelfall in Frankreich
wir wollen nicht dass Ruhe einkehrt wir
machen weiter gegen die Polizei ihren
Rassismus gegen eine Polizei die tötet
gegen die Gewalt des Staates
die Spannung entlädt sich heute schon am
Nachmittag in den Vorstädten fühlen sie
sich Beamten ausgeliefert die in
jüngster Zeit immer wieder Grenzen
überschritten haben die wiederum klagen
über Überlastung und Mangel in den
Respekt die Eskalation scheint beiden
Seiten fremd
ich habe für diese Nacht 40.000
Polizisten zusammengerufen 5000 für den
Großraum Paris und sie sind mit
entsprechender Technik ausgestattet um
die Ausschreitungen zu bekämpfen damit
die Ordnung der Republik
wiederhergestellt wird
die Sorge ist groß dass ich solche
Szenen wie in der vergangenen Nacht
wiederholen Autos und mülltonnenbrennen
Rathäuser werden zerstört beim
Krisentreffen verurteilt der Präsident
die Krawalle
die vergangenen Stunden waren geprägt
durch Gewaltakte gegen eine Polizeiwache
Schulen Rathäuser also gegen die
Institutionen und die Republik diese
Handlungen sind durch nichts zu
rechtfertigen
[Musik]
die Wut entfacht hat dieses Video dass
ich rasend schnell verbreitete ein
Polizist der schießt bei einer
Verkehrskontrolle einen Polizei
bekannten 17-Jährigen der Staatsanwalt
ermittelt wegen Totschlags dass es sich
um Notwehr handelte wird angezweifelt
die Staatsanwaltschaft ist der
Auffassung dass die Waffe nicht
rechtmäßig eingesetzt wurde der Polizist
befindet sich inzwischen in
Untersuchungshaft es ist nicht das erste
Mal in Frankreich das eine
Verkehrskontrolle tödlich endet oft
trifft es Bewohner der Mond und so rührt
der Fall an Wunden die im Land immer
wieder aufreißen
die Realität der Menschen hier bei uns
hat nichts mit der Realität der
Hauptstadt zu tun hier in den
Hochhaussiedlungen ist die Polizei
einfach überall
angespannt aggressiv ist die Stimmung
auch an diesem Abend wieder hin und her
und anderen Orts für das Wochenende
wurden lokale Ausgangssperren verhängt
all das deutet darauf hin dass sich der
Zorn in Frankreich nicht so schnell
wieder legt
was nutzt ein Krankenhausbett wenn es
kein Pflegepersonal gibt um die
Patienten darin zu versorgen das ist ja
das große Dilemma in der deutschen
Krankenhaus Landschaft es gibt zwar
viele Kliniken aber zu wenig Personal
und zu wenig Geld
hinzukommen teils erhebliche
Qualitätsunterschiede was jetzt
natürlich auch nicht so überraschend ist
natürlich gibt es in einer großen
städtischen Universitätsklinik mehr
Spezialisten und neueste Technik aber
sollen kleinere Kliniken im ländlichen
Raum deshalb geschlossen werden die
geplante krankenhausreform des
Bundesgesundheitsministers könnte das
zur Folge haben seine Kollegen aus den
Bundesländern laufender gegen Sturm ein
Grundsatzstreit bei dem beide Seiten
trifft die Argumente anführen können
Frank Buchwald berichtet
in Spremberg tickt die Uhr zwei Jahre
kann das kleine Krankenhaus in der
Niederlausitz wohl noch weitermachen
viele die hier arbeiten haben deshalb
auf einen Teil ihrer Gehälter verzichtet
was dann aber geschieht was noch keiner
Deutschlands Kliniken stecken tief in
den roten Zahlen fast 7,4 Milliarden
Euro Defizit allein in diesem Jahr pro
Stunde machen die Krankenhäuser
572.000 Euro Miese zahlen die dem
Gesundheitsminister nicht egal sein
können die Länder wollen mehr Geld vom
Bund Lauterbach aber hat das nicht
eine allgemeine Rettungsaktion für alle
Krankenhäuser im System eine Gießkanne
erschöpft sich über alle Krankenhause
dafür fehlt dem Bund das Geld und das
auch unklar wozu das führen würde der
Minister sitzt deshalb auf
Spezialisierung er will Krankenhäuser
künftig in drei versorgungsgrade
einteilen Levels genannt kleine Kliniken
für die wohnortnahe Grundversorgung
spezialisierte Krankenhäuser für
fachbehandlungen
Maximalversorgung mit Spitzenmedizin in
wenigen Unikliniken für die Patienten
bedeutet das zwar möglicherweise bessere
Behandlung aber auch weitere Wege und
weniger Besuch das kommt nicht gut an
die Länderminister können ein Lied davon
singen
was wir nicht wollen ist dass er bloß
den levelungs suggeriert nur dieses
Level an jede Woche kommt ein Klinik ein
Kreistag zu mir oh mein Krankenhaus 40
Millionen Euro gegeben habe in Hohenlohe
in Öhringen weiß gar nicht zu welches
Level es gehört Klaus hollect Lukas CSU
Kollege aus Bayern kriegt zwar nicht
ganz so echauffiert stößt aber ins
gleiche Horn
Spezialisierung ja aber nicht pauschal
sagen es gibt hier wenige gute Qualität
und es hat alles nur mit
Wirtschaftlichkeit zu tun das trifft die
Menschen draußen die dort arbeiten ganz
massiv noch ein Streitpunkt die
Transparenzrichtlinie welche
Qualitätsstandards eine Klinik bei
bestimmten Behandlungen erfüllt und wo
es möglicherweise Mängel gibt sollen
Patienten ab Januar mit wenigen Klicks
im Internet ermitteln können in die
Bewertung will Lauterbach Daten wie die
Behandlungszahlen für den jeweiligen
Eingriff in einer Klinik einfließen
lassen dazu Komplikationsraten
facharztdichte und
pflegepersonalausstattung die
Krankenhäuser aber Kontern wer
veröffentlichen alle unsere
Qualitätsberichte mit allen Daten die
Herr Lauterbach auch angesprochen hat
aber wir laufen Sturm gegen pseudo
wissenschaftliche Daten die er zuletzt
veröffentlicht hat so wird Minister
Lauterbach noch eine Menge
Überzeugungskraft brauchen viele kleine
Krankenhäuser aber wissen nicht wie es
weitergeht in Spremberg haben sie zwei
Jahre Zeit immerhin die Uhr aber tickt
und mit dem Blick auf die
wirtschaftliche Lage in Deutschland geht
es bei dir jetzt weiter Heinz die
Inflation ist im Juni wieder leicht
gestiegen davor hatte sich die Teuerung
seit Februar kontinuierlich abgeschwächt
nun ist allerdings für den Juni auch von
Sondereffekten die Rede Frank bedmann wo
stehen wir also aktuell in Sachen
Inflation ja auf dem Weg nach unten
machen die Preise ein kleines Päuschen
so jedenfalls sehen es die meisten
Experten und werden dann nicht eben jene
Sondereffekte im letzten Sommer gewesen
die Inflation wäre wohl jetzt auch im
Juni weiter zurückgegangen so aber haben
die Einführung des neuen euro-tickets
und des tankrabatts die Preise im
letzten Jahr vorübergehend künstlich
gedrückt und dafür gesorgt wenn man die
gedrückten mit den aktuellen Preisen
vergleicht vergleicht das diese auf
Jahres Sicht wieder deutlicher geschätzt
um 6,4% gestiegen sind zuvor verringerte
sich die Teuerung in Deutschland mehrere
Monate in Folge für die zweite
Jahreshälfte rechnen viel im übrigen
damit
hat sich der Trend dieser Entspannung
bei den Preisen fortsetzt trotzdem wird
Auto von gesprochen die inflationser
hartnäckig die Teuerung noch lange ein
Problem widerspricht sie das nicht die
Europäische Zentralbank die schaut sich
natürlich auch noch andere Zahlen an
besondere Sorge bereitet ihr da die
Kerninflation dabei sagt man wir lassen
mal die Energie und die
Lebensmittelpreise weg und schauen nur
was die anderen Preise machen also die
Preise für Kleidung für Essen gehen für
Urlaub machen und da stellen die
Währungshüter fest keine Entspannung die
Kerninflation ist hierzulande seit
Jahresanfang also tatsächlich hartnäckig
das ist kein gutes Zeichen von daher ist
dieses Thema Teuerung noch lange nicht
ausgestanden vielen Dank Frank Wittmann
bei Audi wird Gernot Döllner neuer
Vorstandsvorsitzender erfolgt wie heute
bekannt gegeben wurde zum ersten
September auf Markus Dussmann Döllner
leitet seit 2021 die Produkte und
Konzernstrategie und das
Generalsekretariat im Volkswagen Konzern
eine Meldung vom Tennis beim
Rasenturnier auf Mallorca hat Jannik
Hansmann nach seinem überraschenden
Erfolg gegen den Weltranglisten
fünftens gestern auch heute seine gute
Form bestätigt hanfmann gewann gegen den
Spanier filiziano Lopez in zwei Sätzen
und der steht damit im Halbfinale des
ATP Turniers
in einer Woche beginnen die Finals die
Tage der Deutschen Meisterschaften bei
der vierten Ausgabe des Multi
Sport-Events werden 159 deutsche
Meistertitel in 18 Sportarten vergeben
hauptaustragungsorte werden Duisburg und
Düsseldorf sein ARD und ZDF übertragen
von Donnerstag bis Sonntag mehr als 25
Stunden live im Fernsehen und 70 Stunden
im Stream ihrer Mediatheken
sezessionen nannten sie ihre Bewegung
Franz von Stuck begann damit in München
es folgten Max Liebermann in Berlin und
Gustav Klimt in Wien hier auf einem Foto
von 1902 mit anderen
sezessionsmitgliedern
Ende des 19 Jahrhunderts vernetzten sich
Künstler die den Aufbruch suchten das
neue das andere die sich austauschten
gegenseitig inspirierten und stärkten in
ihrer Revolution des Kunstbetriebs
in Erinnerung an diese Zeit und ihre
Künstler und auch Künstlerinnen gibt es
eine neue Ausstellung in Berlin die
insbesondere Klimt Fans begeistern wird
Stefan Merseburger hat sie sich
angesehen
geradezu magnetisch zieht er einen an
dieser Blick verführerisch
unwiderstehlich und gefährlich judith
ist eine moderne vom fatal ein
Meisterwerk des Wiener Jugendstil Stars
Gustav Klimt einmal erst war diese
Kostbarkeit in Berlin zu sehen
1905 war die Judith von Klimt hier in
Berlin auf einer sezessionsausstellung
zu sehen und das war tatsächlich das
letzte Mal dass wir sie hier in Berlin
zu Gast hatten umso größer ist die
Freude jetzt dass wir sie wieder hier
haben können
doch damit nicht genug auch Emilie Flüge
klims Lebensgefährtin wurde aus Wien
nach Berlin geschickt Serena polizeid
Lederer ist eine Leihgabe aus New York
so viel klimt war noch nie in Berlin die
Ausstellung in der Alten Nationalgalerie
ist hochkarätig die sezessionen die
Abspaltungen vom traditionellen
Kunstbetrieb in München Wien und Berlin
Ende des 19 Jahrhunderts wollten den
Umbruch
[Musik]
im Vergleich wird deutlich was sie als
gemeinsame Ziele hatten sie wollten alle
Anschluss an die westlichen avangaten an
die künstlerischen Neuheiten egal
welcher Stil Impressionismus Jugendstil
oder auch Symbolismus und sie wollten
sich vernetzen und eine neue Form des
Ausstellens von zeitgenössischer Kunst
die erste sezessionsausstellung findet
1892 in München statt der Symbolist
Franz von Stuck wählt Pallas Athene die
Göttin der Kampfkunst und Weisheit als
Schutzpatronin für die Ausstellung fünf
Jahre später zieht Gustav Klimt nach
auch ermalt Palas Athene als
Schutzgöttin der ersten Wiener Secession
also ich bin mittlerweile zu der
Erkenntnis gekommen dass wenn es die
Münchner Sezession nicht schon gegeben
hätte ich bin nicht sicher ob die Wiener
dass alleine von sich aus gewagt hätten
auch eben eine Sezession in Angriff zu
nehmen
in der Impressionist Max Liebermann ist
die Lichtgestalt der Berliner Sezession
die sich 1899 gründete
Käthe Kollwitz war Mitglied nur in
Berlin konnten Frauen der Vereinigung
beitreten in Wien und München durften
sie lediglich ausstellen und
gleichberechtigt waren Frauen damals
nirgends
sie durften nicht auf die Akademie sie
durften nicht abzeichnen sie haben
allenfalls irgendwelche
Privatunterricht genommen
Selbstbildnis von Anna hillermann im
Atelier einen aktmahend ein Akt des
Protestes es gibt großartige Malerinnen
zu entdecken sezessionen Brüche mit
Gebräuchen was einst schockierte ist
heute einfach nur schön
[Musik]
das war es von uns gleich geht's wie
schon angekündigt weil Maybrit Illner
weiter und um 0:30 Uhr gibt es dann
unsere heute schon Update mit einer und
das morgen wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der Juni war
eigentlich viel zu trocken nur 60
Prozent der üblichen Regenmenge ist
runtergekommen und das war auch noch
sehr unterschiedlich verteilt was wir
hier sehen durchaus große Regenmengen
100 bis 200% über 200% kam tatsächlich
in der Mitte runter das ist auf das
Unwetter tief Lambert zurückzuführen
wenn wir nach Norden schauen da kam kaum
Regen dazu und der Juni war der 14 Juni
in Folge der zu warm war so viel zur
Statistik denn es kommt beim Wetter
neuer Regen dazu hier diese Kaltfront
die erreicht uns unverlagert sich
südostwärts dann gibt es im Osten
kräftigen Regen oder auch im Süden und
örtlich kann es auch zu Unwettern kommen
in der Nacht also gibt es schon Regen
der sich südostwärts verlagert
durchsetzt mit Gewittern bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von 12 Grad an den Alpen
und 18 Grad im Südwesten das ist die
Temperaturspanne häufig ist es aber doch
eine recht milde Nacht und morgen am
Nachmittag sieht es etwa so aus im Osten
kräftige Gewitter und auch im Süden und
Unwetter sind auch möglich ganz im
Westen lockertes bereits schon wieder
auf hinter der Kaltfront Temperaturen
erreichen höchste Werte von 27 Grad im
Osten und 19 Grad am Alpenrand auch die
nächsten Tage gibt es noch Schau und
Gewitter aber die sind nicht mehr ganz
so heftig 19 bis 26 am Samstag und
Sonntag gibt es schon deutlich mehr
Wolkenlücken und damit ein schönen Abend